[Music] It
's
against the rules to
hug you from behind Dogs, girls
Ufufu
With this, I can convey my thoughts
Pull my body
What is it
[music]
God with
me?  Kenta will die too
So the center will die in a way that follows me I can't get out of it So I can't feel it when I enter It's
beautiful, isn't it?
You can't get enough of
it, so stay strong Please, child who fell in a critical situation, let it
grow  If you can feel the warmth,
wake
up I really wanted my feelings to reach you I really want
to go to a place where radio waves are coming in I'll go to a place where radio waves can be received and send nails to myself and Kaho It's a
6 format Water
to the center A
of course  Forgive me
ana